I like to support the people around
me why is that the biggest laugh in a
while I do my God I like to lift and
Elevate those around me out my water
like punch down and bury my only joy my
only real Joy is watching those around
me Thrive by the way I'm I'm hostage
right now I'm being I'm being held at
gunpoint being forced to read this no I
I uh I do I'm happy but then there
limits there are limits and Matt gorley
a very talented fellow you know works on
this podcast you add so much to the
chitter chatter but then behind the
scenes you're constantly uh making all
these great edits and audio choices and
you're putting it all together and
getting it out to the people of the
world so I do commend you for that but
then you have these other projects and
um I'm trying to think of the way to put
this it enrages me that you would ever
divert your eye from this I mean this is
a golden egg this is a lightning in a
bottle what we have here and yet every
time I turn around you say well I got to
get going now I'm going to go work on
gloop Dilly gloop and I'm like what's
that and you're like oh it's a it's one
of my 700 other podcasts that I do you
have one called Mall walking is that
right yeah that's a culturally
significant and important podcast where
my friend Mark and I just record
ourselves walking through America's
malls mhm and you've been uh manhandled
during that during those recordings
haven't you have yeah Sona joined us
once and we got kicked out well you make
it sound like it was we got kicked out
because of me no you were you were what
did you shoplift just curious how dare
you what did you well one time when we
how dare you have you shoplifted in the
past no we did reparations well yeah we
went to the store that I did shoplift
from and then we I apologized oh good
all right that's uh and we bought
something from the store to a tone yeah
that's nice okay well you Matt mat did
yeah so so you have these other you have
and you have a lot of other projects as
well it's true and I look at those as
Moonlighting this is my day job this is
you know I'm I take this seriously you
do I I mean I just worry that even
though they existed before this podcast
but still I know but come on this this
SP you know you're a guy that's uh been
mucking around making little sculptures
and then you got a chance to work on I
mean this is the Parthenon it sits
upon you know this is a massive
structure that sits on a high Mesa in
Hill in Athens and people look at it in
Marvel at it's Beauty corporate entity
that's rotting America from within I
think is an apt analogy yeah you say
tomato I say tomato but the important
thing uh is that you do have these other
podcasts and even I have to admit
someone with a grinch shriveled heart
like me I have to admit that you do have
these other ideas that sound cool and
you have these other projects that that
sound like they're kind of interesting
and you've got this new one that I heard
about uh Adam mentioned it to me in the
hall today and I said wait a minute that
sounds like a really good idea I'd
listen to that and I I wanted to bring
it up on the air that's very nice of you
I mean I will say that my podcasts are
stupid this one is legit oh this is arod
di it is I'll tell you why because my
wife and I are doing it together and she
adds a level of respectability that I
cannot bring well okay let's talk about
this because the project that you're
working on uh is called keys to the
kingdom and what's interesting this is
about the experience of working at a
theme park and first of all that's how
you met your wife is that that's right
we're both recovering theme park
employees she was a former princess she
played a bunch of princesses I was just
kind of a like actor performer improv
person there and we met at Universal
Studios that we both worked at Disney
together and through the years we were
beset some of ourselves through crazy
stories of that goes on there that
you wouldn't believe in this whole
podcast is like a eight episode docu
series of people telling stories about
when they worked there essentially you
guys are the hosts and then uh you're
talking to a bunch of people you know
who who are coming forward and just
telling you the funny crazy things that
happened to them while they were working
in theme pars yeah and some people we
don't know and some people actually that
are going under assumed names and having
their voices changed because they're
either worried about job security or
past job security they might not even
work there and they still don't want to
upset certain theme parks so there's a
lot of like um you know it's kind of a
tongue and cheek Watergate expose oh but
you know what I mean I thought I thought
the original Watergate expose was kind
of tongue and
cheek we're treating it like we're like
we're busting the lid off something when
in fact we're just having a good time
with some stories that are really
ridiculous some stories that are kind of
spooky and then Sona was a guest as well
and she tells her story of getting
busted by the Disney police for having
trying to smuggle in EDI St Park yeah
yeah I did wife told that story on this
podcast yeah and also you don't even
need to tell me what it was cuz you
could guess what Sonic got in trouble
for it usually revolves around a certain
theme uh but um keys to the kingdom and
how do people listen to keys to the
kingdom it's anywhere you can find
podcasts and um it'll be out October
16th but you could subscribe now there's
uh also eight behind the scenes bonus
episodes with extra material that you
can get uh in the show notes of the
podcast well it sounds uh like I said I
would listen to this because as someone
who has been to every time I go to a
theme park my mind is racing wondering
what's really going on here it's CRA and
there's no way to find out because you
can't just ask people but uh it sounds
like you have you've blown the lid off
this story it's a crazy creepy cult that
we were a part of for a long time and
I'm happy to be out of it yeah mhm but
also all respect to these major
companies oh God and uh I look forward
to doing business with you in the future
because I didn't just say that well
anyway uh look out for it keys to the
kingdom and uh I'm I'm excited for you
thank you this was very nice of you to
do too by well this will never air okay
I'll just make sure it's not even being
recorded yeah no no make sure this never
ever airs I just want points for doing
it and then just make sure it never
really happens okay cool that's the
Conan
formula